hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to a few terrible games and
now what do I mean by terrible games I
think you all know they're pretty much
on the low end of reviews on Steam
they're of questionable quality they're
of a questionable content and generally
all around I just don't understand why
they were made in the first place
but sometimes you get games that are so
bad that they spin all the way around
the wheel of quality back to hilarious
so I'm gonna see if that happens now
with a game called milky boobs what it
is all [ __ ] alright so milky boobs is oh
I did not need that it's a game where oh
boy how do I even describe it maybe I I
think what I have to do a I have to read
you what the store page says about this
game before we even get started about
this okay so this game comes in at a
mixed rating a whopping 53% only 28
reviews but milky boobs says oh oh my
god paradise the summer has come and
what could be better than to relax at
the beach with some gorgeous ladies
having fun but then [ __ ] got real maybe
it was the Sun maybe it was because too
many mojitos on the beach maybe it was
out of feminism but suddenly all the
beautiful girls went crazy and got too
hot now there is only one thing you can
do to cool them down milk lots of cool
extra juicy milk good thing you always
have that milk blast through with you
and are ready to rescue who managed by
cooling down some hot babes but why me I
hear you crying because life doesn't get
better than this
okay so protect the beach babes from
overeating take a cooling break at the
beach with a boobie resort refresh more
boobie base than you could ever dream of
most importantly milk them all see yeah
that doesn't make any sense at all chill
mode rescue some cute girls from
overheating in the relaxing chill mode
or well don't simply lean back and enjoy
the scenery
everything is chilled in this mode grill
mode [ __ ] is getting serious the babes
are so hot they're literally on fire
better don't get too close to them or
you will get hurt
I see that one
they don't like that at all never played
this game before but I can only assume
that it is of incredible quality it's
whoa what was that it's freaking out and
all the babes are going crazy there's
only one thing that can help take your
milk gun and refresh them with your
amazing white liquid but only milk them
when they're overheating whoa whoa
ladies ladies ladies ladies ladies oh it
doesn't want to cool down all right that
one's just okay that's bugged apparently
okay this one's just not cooling down I
guess nope I guess it just doesn't work
anymore I'm out of okay all right
why why why why why why why I just
wanted to milk you it doesn't work it
doesn't work it doesn't it doesn't what
it doesn't work I got burned seems like
those hot babes were tomb we're we're
we're too much to handle again shall we
again
yes okay again I'm gonna go with again
okay pick up 50 milks I got it okay all
right so far so good uh sorry ma'am
sorry oh why are you unhappy okay I did
not
all right hey whoa whoa whoa don't get
too close what happens if you just run
in the water why couldn't have just have
a super soaker oh they don't even go in
the water they all right ah you
beautiful ladies please get the hell
away from me hmm if I see in the water
I'm fine right
you can't get me when I'm in the water
okay that doesn't make any sense there's
a lot of fire seems to be a problem here
so you tell me that I could just break
the game and I can stay in the water go
up get milk jump back in the water and
I'll be fine
yep this game is incredible why does
this even have a 50% why does this even
have any ratings that are positive at
all okay now it works okay that doesn't
make any sense also where'd the steam
coming from that's okay all right I
don't like that I don't know why you
just have to collapse and spasm as soon
as they hit them with my milk sorry lady
very sorry I don't know why you're
congregating behind the bar okay okay
nope nope doesn't register
I'm literally splatting my milk all over
you
they're immune to my milk oh [ __ ] those
clothes how do women are here and how
many women are just on fire all the time
you lady
I can't sight though how'd you dodge
that what are you in the matrix be in
the milk Trix the milk Matrix Blue's
Blue's Blue's Clues flew sploosh okay
sploosh sploosh Blue's Clues I don't
like the giggles as the thing I don't
like the giggles it's just a constant
stream of giggles hello can you please
stop okay well that's great I'll go try
chill mode all right I'm gonna go to
boobie Bay ha ha ha ha chill mode oh god
I've never had such a splatty game
before but he's perfectly innocent this
isn't a euphemism for anything at all
it's totally just splatting women with
milk which is not good by itself but you
know if you think about it it's not that
terrible
sorry all right ladies all right well
I'm getting about 15 frames and say okay
and women are falling over wherever they
are which oh I didn't do that
you seem to be fine ma'am you know you
could just take a swig of milk by
yourself even though there's wine in
here okay more milk for me press F to
pick up oh I didn't press F I just walk
into it
you're lying to me you say press F to
pick up it's okay sorry ladies sorry
you want some sorry sorry I'm sorry oh
hi hello okay sorry you got in the way
of that one that's not my fault oh boy
there you go lady oh the framerate is
great on this game oh I hate it when
they just walk right into my line of
fire like that hello
you didn't need them okay you don't need
milk but there you go wait what am i
wearing my SWAT officer the my the
milkman milkman here hello ladies I see
you're all hiding from my milk
may I please please cool thee okay
now cool you down I suppose I uh okay
this is a fun game great milk man feels
godless with his life how'd you feel
good knowing that I give all the ladies
of this island exactly what they want
low frame rate and way too much milk I
don't know if this game sends the right
message I'm not sure what message this
game sends but I'm pretty sure it's not
the right one yep okay all right oh oh
um sorry yeah I think I feel
accomplished enough for one lifetime in
there I just don't like when they spread
up to me and stare at me like that no I
don't want to give you my milk ah I
don't give you my mouth okay
all right you know what I'm gone I'm
done that's enough of that I'm leaving
we don't need that anymore this is
whiplash and on its surface and
according to the trailer it actually may
seem like a fun and interesting game
however it is anything but that it comes
in at a whopping 30% positive rating on
Steam and it probably is inspired if not
completely copied from goat simulator
but as you can see
it is anything but that it runs at a bar
it runs out of fantastical two frames a
second right and instead of being funny
at how bad the physics is it is instead
just plain ol bad all right
yep this is I haven't actually played
this before but I I'm pretty sure I I
could've okay I can't get up again ah
here we go instructions perfect okay are
to go in and out of ragdoll perfect okay
nevermind it only goes in to rag doll it
doesn't go out of ragdoll it only goes
into ragdoll okay alright that's not how
that works
all right you know what I'm just gonna
respawn I'm just gonna read nope I'm
still in ragdoll can't get out of it
okay can I start nope
can I respawn nope okay I'm just like
this forever now I don't get a choice at
all how do I get out how do there's an
entire city outside of this how do I get
out why am I still okay
why did I teleport through that can I
let me leave please
Eadie's you need the key you need a key
to the outside door you need to find a
okay I think I see the key it's right
next to the goddamn door of course it is
why would it not be right there alright
okay alright I've found a way to fly
apparently okay alright that is normal I
don't know where it's taking me but here
we go
can I please get somewhere what I'm just
going into the desert now sorry my
people need me I have to believe okay if
I kick I if I kick I steep going up yep
if I keep kicking I just fly well found
out a fly that's nice this awful you
you'd think it wouldn't I'm trapped in
this guy now oh that's unpleasant to
look at alright well hi I'm stuck in the
middle of the air that doesn't make any
sense at all can't get out of ragdoll
odhh can I respawn please thank you
thank you very much we I hate okay oh
boy great yes you think that it would
not be hard to make a goat simulator
clone that is in some way fun okay
Brooks okay okay okay no I'm not falling
through the world I'm clearly in the
world I feel like I need to play goat
simulator next just to compare how much
better goat simulator is at being a
completely broken game how you doing oh
boy oh I'm so sorry yeah sorry now you
are trapped in the perpetual nightmare
of ragdoll mode hello
sorry oh hey how's it going there were
you waving at each other sorry
okay never mind I take back everything I
said about this game because this game
suddenly became a maze excuse me mind if
I just nudge man this game is pretty
amazing
alright let's fly I guess don't mind is
that cartwheel down Main Avenue here
what what wait wait whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa are you Wyatt why sorry I
didn't mean to interrupt your tree
KISSING I'm very sorry about that oh
okay you're still kissing okay well that
seems to be what are you are you taking
a poop never mind you're taking to death
okay
oh I don't know why their spines
instantly decide to break okay they just
go to a figure s by the time they die
sorry are you swimming okay can I have
this cupcake all right I got a cupcake
one of fifty there's no way oh hi
there's no way in the world I would go
through this game enough to get 50
cupcakes hey do these actually work also
what the [ __ ] um all right sorry sorry
sorry and how much weed do I have to
smoke to never have that in my brain
ever again hello dear
never mind you're an impenetrable deer
also what the hell is happening over
here okay sorry sorry sorry sorry
sorry very sorry about that okay now
that I've ruined your cult I think or
you're better off I have no idea I see a
car over there let me go grab that maybe
that's gonna make this marginally more
interesting I mean not that it's that
bad I guess hey boats in the ground
there yeah those may i press e to you Oh
Oh
hold shift for turbo sorry alright not
that bad I guess oh there's no traction
okay there's no excuse for how bad that
handles okay there's no traction
whatsoever
I can't drive I'm out apparently all
right well that was fun I'll never do
that ever again I'm just gonna cartwheel
my respawn
Oh oh my god what the [ __ ] I'm finally
back oh my god I'm finally out of
ragdoll mode Wow
well we while you are we this isn't
nearly as interesting though I've got
marginally better control over my hello
how are you doing it sorry guy admit I
kind of liked it better when I was
sliding on my ass ooh a bike can I Drive
that oh okay that's one how how what are
you why are you holds E to front-flip
that's okay I guess that's how that
works
what are you doing huh okay I just like
Oh
and I'm down here now what what what
what okay and I guess I'm just
perpetually down here now all right okay
that's great there we go and I'm back in
[ __ ] here all right all right is
there like a demon mode I wish I really
hope this demon mode because I was just
looking okay never mind that I guess I'm
not gonna do anything I wanted to do
sorry sorry I didn't even kick you all
right I think I've plumbed the depths of
the quality of this particular game and
I don't think it's gonna get any better
any time soon but yeah this is oh and I
got a sorry um I don't even oh okay
didn't expect you to keep twitching I
think your rag doll is still trying to
dance that's not okay I'm just gonna go
up these stairs oh good another one hey
your twin - okay that's not right okay
I'm just gonna kick the [ __ ] out of you
sorry I think I'm done with this [ __ ]
all right so that is crash world ooh
whiplash crash valley whatever it
doesn't even say the game here but
apparently there's a bunch of quests if
you want to try it there's dolphins too
and ghosts so that was bad but this next
game should be good I don't even know I
don't even know what to say in the face
of these games none of them even make
any sense yeah it's just like goat
simulator gave every other developer an
excuse to be like I'll make a shitty
good I can make a shitty game I'll make
a shitty game and I'll put it on Steam
and it's whopping cost will be six
dollars for this piece of garbage mostly
negative 35% all right so this next game
actually might be amazing it's called oh
it's called kickin kittens
[Music]
Putin saves the world your Intelligence
Agency has informed you of sinister
alien plot aliens have disguised robots
as kittens to sneak into Russia and
launch its nuclear payload which would
start World War three stop the alien
robot kittens by collecting all ten
symbols of manliness so Putin can
destroy the alien invasion okay I don't
understand any of that but I'm gonna try
my bit Oh Oh fighters I don't know what
the [ __ ] is happening oh okay all right
weird word oh my go wow wow wow oh it's
not so bad I think I can't quite tell
but I'm gonna assume that it's not so
bad oh boy how many these are actual
kittens and how many are actually robots
yeah okay sure thanks aliens for being
bastards
I don't even know if I can have any wire
they're flying this at all why is every
flying cats oh my god I can't beat it
really done anymore okay well I guess
now we're all doomed
sorry we're doomed sorry rush I just for
some reason I don't think I'm gonna be
able to do this I've got nothing to say
I've got no intelligent words to say
about any of this it's just cats
it's just Putin it's just kitten there's
there's absolutely nothing
Oh Oh cuddles Oh a boss and you ain't
gonna give me if there's one thing I'm
good at its yanking my mouse oh wow I
did it I'm so proud of myself I'm so
proud of Putin and his amazing delts are
you gonna make it ever harder for me I'm
already so good at the game you can't
possibly think that it would be any
worse Oh God how how in the [ __ ] yeah we
do
I don't think Putin's gonna make it
through this one ah Borden's Borden's
ain't gonna do it anybody do the
curtains doing anything I can't even
tell anymore Putin's just a blur of
manliness and abs oh boy well there's
the end for me I think maybe not whoa
[ __ ] I'm not actually 100% this game oh
man this is gonna give me wrist cramps I
just gotta fling back and forth as hard
as I can oh my god play or its cramping
up
Putin can't do it Putin K bleed the
kitten kill oh oh oh my god I'm really
trying as hard as I can guys but my
shoulder is cramping up there we go well
I've failed I failed I'm a big failure
yes oh well I think that's enough for
now I'm pretty sure the screen kind of
symbolizes the whole adventure in this
game here but this has been three
terrible terrible games hope you guys
enjoyed it and I know that you guys know
some games that are so bad they are good
not that these were so bad they're good
these are so bad that they're bad but if
you guys know some games that are just
so bad that they really touch a special
place in your heart let me know down in
the comments below I actually love
seeing just the bottom of the barrel of
what gaming can be these days so if
you've got ideas let me know thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you thought of these games in
the comments below maybe you want to
play these games I'll provide them in
the description if you really do so
thank you again and as always I will see
you in the next video bye-bye
[Music]